I heard you were back.
I'm going to Mandalore.
May the force be with you.
You ready for an adventure?
A mandalorian.
Know their way around.
That way you'll never be lost.
The Mandalorian. Season three March 1st.
Only on Disney Plus.
Welcome back, everyone is Charly.
This is the way they dropped a brand
new Mandalorian Season three trailer.
There's a bunch of new footage,
so we'll break it down.
I will be doing videos for all the
episodes, just like I did for season one.
Season two.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
Also do a special giveaway
and those episode videos too.
We're entering this zone where it's
going to cross over with the last of US.
We're like in Pedro
Pascal into the Pascal verse right now.
In on that show, he's protecting Ellie
in a very grogu Mando like situation,
like a dad like figure adopting someone,
so to speak, and trying to protect them.
But you,
starting with the brand new footage
at the beginning of the trailer,
it starts with a voiceover
from Greef Karga,
who's the new administrator on Navarro
Like he's
taken over the administration of the town,
which is the job that the client had in
season one.
The only ever called him the client.
They never really gave him a name.
He was just meant to be
the imperial officer
that was left on the planet
serving as administrator
in such a remote planet to the outer end
that usually in situations like that,
the empire or the remnants of the empire,
as they're trying to come back
now through Grand
Admiral Thrawn and Moff Gideon,
they would only keep skeleton
crews on planets like that,
and usually they would give officers
jobs like that as a form of punishment,
like we're going to banish
you kind of by putting you
in this backwater planet
in the middle of nowhere.
But the real secret was they were keeping
their imperial cloning facility there.
The Doctor Pershing was using
his whole thing,
was conducting experiments
in cloning force sensitive beings.
Doctor purging,
as you can see, featured prominently
in all The New Mandalorian season
three trailers.
So we know they're going to finally
be picking back up with that Grogu
cloning storyline.
It seemed like a really big deal,
but we only got a little bit of it
during season two.
I think the whole Grogu cloning storyline
is part of their heir to the Empire
Thrawn trilogy story
that they're trying to adapt
for The Mandalorian
and all the connected spinoffs
like the Ahsoka series,
now the Skeleton Crew series,
like they're doing a version of The Heir
to the Empire in the TV shows set
right
after the events of Return of the Jedi,
because that's basically what it took
place in the novels back in the nineties.
That was the Legends storyline,
but they've already re canonized
some of that stuff.
Like Dave Filoni brought Thrawn back,
they brought some other characters
back already
and now it seems that they're bringing
a bunch of story elements
from that into present day as well,
just swapping some of the characters.
But during that original Thrawn book
storyline, Thrawn
found the clone of a Jedi master
and tried to use his force abilities
to make his fleet better fighters.
He would have the Jedi master enhance
the fleet's senses, their connectedness
through the force so that they'd be
a more cohesive fighting force.
Thrawn had believed that the Empire used
to be so effective because the Emperor,
at least according to his beliefs,
would do that to his fleet.
So like the Emperor himself
would basically give the entire fleet
a jolt of coffee to the brain
using the dark side of the force.
Eventually, Luke Skywalker
and the others found one of the Empire's
hidden mountain fortresses
where he kept Jedi and Sith artifacts
and other ultra powerful, rare
super weapons.
Just things that he wanted to keep hidden.
And he had secret bases like that
all over the galaxy, inside
the one that Luke and the others go to.
They learned the Emperor had recovered
Luke's severed hand
that Darth Vader cut off
during their fight in Empire Strikes Back.
Thrawn in the remnants of the empire
that he's trying to resurrect
like the story is called
Heir to the Empire.
And Thrawn
is meant to be the heir to the Empire.
They wind up using the hand
to clone Luke Skywalker.
So you have a Luke Skywalker versus
his clone situation
and also then fighting the clone
Jedi master who winds up going mad.
Cloning for sensitive beings.
Not a smart thing to do.
A lot of Jedi
cloning going on during that series.
They also kind of use that twist
in the rise of Skywalker
to bring back the empire.
But the twist, I think, was more inspired
by the Dark Empire
comic book series where the Emperor did
the exact same thing.
Like literally it's the exact same story.
He would periodically transfer
his consciousness
to younger clones of himself
when his older bodies were out,
or if he was killed or thrown down
giant elevator shafts on The Mandalorian.
It seems like Dr.
Pershing came out of the remnants of the
Kamino cloning facility in the prequels,
like he's
wearing their symbol on his uniform.
The Emperor claimed
he shut it down
out for Revenge of the Sith,
but secretly
he just had them continue their research.
It's just that
he didn't want anyone else in the galaxy
trying to create their own clone army
that could challenge the Empire.
Now it seems like they might have to show
grand Admiral Thrawn, who
we haven't seen yet, but we know he exists
because they mentioned him during season
two in Moff Gideon trying to create force
sensitive troopers to make them stronger
like force
sensitive clones that they can 3D print.
Imagine printing yourself a Jedi army
that you could control
because that's the whole twist of order 66
is they have controls built into them,
so they're kind of like finger puppets
to the emperor.
Basically.
It essentially make the remnants
of the empire unstoppable.
But as at the beginning of season
three, Ahsoka is still looking for Thrawn
and they've revealed
that he and Ezra Bridger with him
have found a way back from the unknown
regions where the space wheel's hyperspace
jumped them during the events of rebels
right before a new hope.
That whole twist is meant to explain
why grand Admiral Thrawn
wasn't around for the events
of the original trilogy.
They were stuck in the unknown regions,
mapping a way out
because the part that they jumped
to wasn't one of the mapped regions.
The Emperor did have Secret Star charts
of some of the unknown regions,
but they're still vast parts of the galaxy
that are completely unmapped by anyone.
So if you wind up in one of those places,
you can't use your hyperspace.
Now the computer to plot a way out.
You have to take the slow way.
Basically, you notice Greef Karga has a
three Poe protocol droid serving him.
It generally seems like he's
cleaned the town up.
Like the town square here
looks
almost like a completely different place,
even though it's meant to be on the same
planet from season one and season two,
It seems like The Mandalorian
tells him his plans
for going to the planet Mandalore
to regain his honor and become a true
mandalorian according to their customs,
or at least according to the hardcore
customs of the sect of the armorer
that he comes from.
The armor and their group are basically
meant to be the remnants of the death.
Watch Mandalorians from the Clone Wars.
They were featured pretty heavily.
And there's a big Jon Favreau
Easter egg link to that.
We saw a flashback of their group
during the Clone Wars
when they were more active
when he was rescued as a child.
This is the symbol of the death
Watch Mandalorians.
So Jon Favreau played the leader
of that group during the Clone Wars.
His name was previously.
They actually created the Darksaber
for his debut on the series.
It was the first appearance
of the Darksaber canonically.
They said that it was created
by his ancestor,
one of the only mandalorians to become
a Jedi star Vizsla Over 1000 years ago,
during the present day of the show,
the heavy infantryman,
who's also voiced by Jon
Favreau, is the descendant
of both of them.
His name is Paz Vizsla.
I don't know if he's meant to be
the son of previously or like a nephew.
It just seems like he's
part of his family.
For a very brief period, Bo-Katan was also
part of Deathwatch, serving previously,
but she eventually left
and formed the Night Owls.
That's one of the reasons
why she was so put off
when she learned where Mando came from.
Like, Oh, you're one of those.
One of the crazy Mandalorians
You remember that?
The armor spoke very poorly of Bo-Katan
too, and the events of what happened
with the Darksaber
during rebels in the fall of their people.
So this sounds like the armor in Bo-Katan
really hate each other.
I really hope that they give them a chance
on the show to have a knockdown,
drag out fight during this scene
of all their characters running around
getting into this big fight.
There's a symbol on a banner here
outside the cave of their cover,
these scenes of Mando and Grogu
talking to the armor,
also probably inside that same cave.
The rocky planet here
just seems like the planet.
Think the armor took their cover too?
You see a bunch more of the mandalorians
that had joined their cover
and a bunch of mandalorian children.
Like they're all wearing armor,
a little tiny armor for those who either
want to see Grogu wearing
a full set of mandalorian armor someday.
He does have the best scar chainmail
that Mando gave him.
We'll probably see him wearing that
at some point
during the season
because he literally chose
the best scar over Yoda's spear, light
saber, lone wolf and cub style.
You must choose one path Grogu
Force Pushes the Alien Monster.
Jon Favreau also said that they would
continue to reference his Jedi
training with Luke Skywalker
and he'd be using the force more.
I don't know that we're going to see
Luke Skywalker cameo again,
but they will be referencing his time
with Luke Skywalker.
His whole arc with Luke
was basically unlocking what force
abilities he'd already developed
and then just kind of hidden
and suppressed within himself
and just remembering a lot of his learning
at the Jedi Temple on course Before
Order 66, he's still got that hot rod
of Naboo Starfighter from the prequels.
I don't know if he'll get another new ship
in future seasons,
but my assumption is, is
they will give him some new ships
eventually.
This celebration
that seems like it's still happening on
tattooing this is leaving Peli motto in.
It also reminds me
of the ending of the special editions
because at the end of the special edition
of Return of the Jedi,
George
Lucas beefed up all the celebrations
on the different planets with fireworks,
more flashbacks of Grogan to order 66,
with someone cutting their way
through the door,
the other Jedi trying to protect him.
I would love for this
to be Anakin Skywalker
and for them to just continue manikins,
push through the Jedi Temple,
killing all the Jedi in the younglings.
The stunt coordinator
on Revenge of the Sith,
Nick Guillard, said that they actually
filmed a bunch more in a can Skywalker
order 66 scenes of them
just ripping through all the Jedi.
But George Lucas thought
that it was too violent for the movie
because it was meant to be PG 13 movie.
In the stuff they had Anakin doing
would have made the movie a Hard-R
It sounds bad ass like I would have loved
to actually seen that.
Then we see the Group of Blue
Mandalorians.
This could be the armors group
because in the other trailers
there were scenes of the armor
fighting in a scene like this.
This is Bo-Katan in the underground
caves of what seemed like the planet
Mandalore with Grogu and Mando.
You notice in this scene of him
talking to Peli motto,
her R5 droid is literally bursting
at the seams with parts falling up.
That's another reference to a new hope
where R five started breaking as he was
wheeling away, allowing R2-D2
to slide his way in
and continue his mission
to find Obi-Wan Kenobi.
When he says The Mandalorian
has to know their way around, we see Dr.
Pershing in a rundown facility.
There's a bunch of scenes of him
on Coruscant as well.
So during season three
we will go to course on.
It seems like he's doing
something really shady,
just trying to access more data
information on his cloning projects.
I don't know which planet this is on,
but these tie interceptors
are chasing Bo-Katan Kryze
in her Mandalorian Starfighter.
If you don't remember, this is her ship.
We saw it briefly during season two.
Katie Sackhoff also said there was a bunch
more bo-katan this season.
You get a bunch more action.
This is also taken from another scene
of the two of them with Grogu.
This is also probably
on the Mandalore planet.
As they explore the caves.
There might be a small cameo scene
during the series to set up the
Ahsoka series because that's taking place
right after the Mandalorian Season three.
In a couple of months,
maybe also Sabine Wren, maybe
also a reference to Grand Admiral Thrawn.
Like we might get a teaser for him
at the end of the season,
but I think they're saving
most of the grand Admiral Thrawn scenes
on screen for the Ahsoka series
just because they're such
a big part of her mission right now
In this part of the timeline, in addition
to Finding Ezra Bridger,
they also might save Ezra Bridger
debuting to the Ahsoka series,
but he's being played by this actor,
so they've already cast him
like they've already filmed the series
a long time ago.
Jude Law's Skeleton Crew series is also
meant to be a spinoff of The Mandalorian,
but it'll be taking place
in a different part of the galaxy
in those characters will not cameo
during The Mandalorian Season three.
We'll see them
for the first time in Skeleton Crew
Episode one at the end of this year.
All my Mandalorian episode videos
will start posting
March 1st after it comes out, so
make sure you enable alerts for my channel
so you don't miss any of that.
Let me know if you have any requests
for Mandalorian Bonus videos to link
for all my other Pedro
Pascal Last of US episodes
down to the description below to everyone.
Click here from my brand new Ant-Man
and the Wasp Quantumania Review video
and click here for my flash trailer video
from the Super Bowl
with a whole bunch of Easter eggs
and a whole bunch of Batman.
Thank you so much for watching,
Everyone. Stay safe.
This is the way.